i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington tonight
if you can't beat him indict him that's
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now in sports if you're a coach without
a winning record you eventually get
fired if you're a ceo and you can't
return value to the shareholders you get
fired
but for liberals in politics and the
media being wrong consistently it's
rarely a disqualifier not from running
for office to push the same policies
that have already failed and not from
appearing on tv
to make more bad predictions
such is the case with all the smug lug
heads forecasting the political demise
of donald trump
i do think trump's influence is waning
and he's only been out of office for
about 10 months so you already see
his influence thankfully wayne
you're going to see that continue in the
next three years donald trump is having
a bad morning because he's become
irrelevant
never trump or republicans never known
for their originality repeated the
mantra
we are starting to see
some of trump's influence wayne that
grip on the republican party is starting
to loosen we know trump's
influence is waning him confident he
would never win president trump's
influence is diminishing
now that's what's called wishful
thinking folks because they desperately
wanted trump gone they let that cloud
whatever sliver of political judgment
they ever had if they had any to begin
with
now check out this map of states where
trump endorsed candidates have won so
far in senate races
now for those of you keeping a score at
home that's eight zero a record in the
senate primaries and in the house
primaries his record is 14 wins and five
losses so that's an overall success rate
for all races senate house and governors
of 95 percent for incumbents and 79
percent for non-incumbents
that winning percentage should become
even more big with the now expected
victory of kerry lake in arizona after
tonight's new batch of counted votes
now whatever you think of trump's
policies his personality
does all of that look like a the record
of someone with waning political
influence
now the establishment view again is
wrong on so many issues it was that
trump was bad for the gop they said that
over and over like he turned people off
women would never vote for him
minorities would run from him
well that's not panning out either
in fact when it comes to minorities the
opposite's the case hispanics are more
favorably inclined toward republicans
than ever before
the democrats have a history of ignoring
what hispanics really want and what they
want is to protect their family they
want law and order they want to be able
to protect their faith and they love
this country and believe in the american
dream
and now republicans view their own party
more favorably than in the pre-trump
years so if that's trump with diminished
influence i'd hate to see trump with
actual influence
so whatever trump decides to do though
in 2024
his ideas are what is the real threat to
the swamp all those never trump ninnies
know that in a second term trump's
agenda would be summed up in one
sentence
no more mr nice guy
so on the chopping block would be the
war on fossil fuels and get rid of that
all things woke at the pentagon that's
gone pro-china bias at the nih oh gone
and federal employees who refused to
turn to return to work
now the latter is an existential threat
to the d.c bureaucracy the sheer size of
the federal civil service it's comprised
of a staggering 2.1
million employees
now when most americans hear that
they're shocked to know of the actual
size of the federal beast
trump's support for a top to bottom
reform of the federal civil service is
terrifying to the thousands of lazy
government employees who are used to
doing nothing and getting paid for it
the office of personnel management's
website yes i went on it today reminds
us that the original civil service act
signed in 1883
ended the spoils system and established
the civil service commission
now the commission led by the energetic
teddy roosevelt laid the foundations of
an impartial
professional civil service based on the
merit principle that employees should be
judged only on how well they can do the
job
that's good well today
teddy has to be rolling in his grave
overwhelmingly the civil service acts
not as an unbiased impartial workforce
but as an arm of the democratic national
committee trump knows this right he
lived it
leftists who were burrowed into agencies
and departments were constantly
undermining his agenda
thus they were thwarting the will of the
people who elected donald trump talk
about anti-democratic that's what the
democrats are always screaming about
that's anti-democratic and as to whether
trump is influential
well his views sure are
according to axios several possible 2024
gop presidential candidates say they
support trump's plan to make it easier
for the president to purge federal
workers
now why does that matter trump need not
win his party's nomination nor even run
again for the next gop president to try
to reimpose that executive order known
as schedule f so democrats increasingly
concerned are scrambling to block that
possibility yeah you bet
and that concern on the part of the
democrats of the civil service reform
it's only growing
just like they needed an insurance
policy to stop trump from winning in
2016
those same forces feel like they need
another insurance policy now
and it might arrive courtesy of a
blatantly political doj investigation
into january 6.
19 months after the capital riots and
they suddenly and panel a federal grand
jury to examine potential criminality
surrounding january 6th
it's beyond obvious
they're worried that trump's not just
going to run again
but that he's going to win again
and rather than take him on on the
court of ideas
they want to take him off the court
altogether
this committee is doing its job
the department of justice needs to do
theirs the department of justice has a
duty to act on this referral and others
we have sent i will echo what my
colleagues have already said but more
bluntly attorney general garland do your
job so that we can do ours
so that you can do yours really
check the inflation numbers sweetie
ain't doing anything
now you know they're panicked when the
ghosts from administrations passed they
start popping up to nudge garland
my guess is that by the end of this
process you're going to see indictments
involving high-level people in the white
house you're going to see indictments
against people outside the white house
ultimately you're probably going to see
the president former president of the
united states indicted as well
now that's rich coming from the master
of the obama hillary cover-up
but that's the only thing that's ironic
it was really ironic when darth vader
showed up
in our nation's 246-year history there
has never been an individual who is a
greater threat to our republic than
donald trump liz is fearless she never
backs down from a fight there is nothing
more important she will ever do
than lead the effort to make sure donald
trump is never again near the oval
office
and she will succeed
that whole thing about never going into
politics again near the oval office
that's funny because that's the sort of
stuff his newfound friends on the left
used to say about him
handing out
billions of dollars in contracts without
a bid to halliburton while you're still
on the payroll makes you unfit to lead
this country you can always tell when
the republicans are restless
because the vice president's motorcade
pulls
into the capitol
and darth vader emerges
and remember these headlines
remember those
you know i'm confused
that's the guy everyone's now supposed
to listen to
on indictments okay
now what you're seeing this week is just
another example of the establishment's
primary emotion these days
it's panic
they know the economy is doing poorly
they know their foreign policy is
failing they know their trade policy
hurts american workers they know that
americans are getting poorer and the
country is getting weaker and they know
elections are coming up in november and
again in 2024
and they know we're on to them because
for the next two years you can expect
more wild charges more threatened
resignations investigations more bad
predictions
but don't lose hope
we're on a path to victory and
establishment they know it and that's
the angle hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else